so
first up here what would you both say is
the biggest
difference between the way you
approached your work on the show
day one compared to this final season is
there any like
new tool in your tool kit so to speak
that you would credit to working on
sabrina
oh my goodness honestly it's so it's so
interesting because i feel like
when i started playing sabrina she was
she was young she was she was dainty she
was excited about
life and and in this one year she's
become
so so weathered she's weathered so
many storms it's like she she's an
entirely new person so just
getting to play that range of a
character uh has given me
just a lot um
a lot of valuable information
and i think just you know speaking to
how brilliant
everyone is from costumes to hair and
makeup you know
depending on whether i was wearing like
this fabulous ball gown or like a a fun
little blazer it felt like i would like
my mood was
always changing depending on what i was
doing
are you laughing at me gavin i don't
know
i just love you
anyway i just feel like she was just
really fun and i i really enjoyed
every iteration of sabrina i felt like
she she had so many different kind of
versions of herself and i'm happy i got
to play all those and experience that
and that gave me a lot to uh to work
with my own life
yeah i mean holy moly how do you even
sum up this kind of experience it taught
me so much
uh i approached the character with a
really
um uh rigorous sort of
discipline in the beginning because i
felt like i really needed to earn it
at some point in there i became a little
too relaxed in it all and and got a
little lazy because it's like you're
playing the same character and you think
you've got it
um and then there's moments where you
realize you don't because as an actor
playing a character
you never really do and you have to do
your homework so it taught me endurance
it taught me discipline it taught me um
how to slow down and enjoy
all of it it taught me to look for clues
and to
not get so pigeon-holed and in one way
of doing
uh you know something as a character it
taught me to take more risks i mean i
could go on
and on and on perry but um truly it's
just
oh so much gratitude for this crazy ride
just to follow up on what you said about
the laziness because i think that this
could be like a
tough thing to discuss or for something
someone to discover on their own
when that happened to you who who kind
of helped you out of it who did you turn
to in order to put all that into
perspective and realize where you were
at
you know i i think it's true i'm going
to speak personally but i feel like a
lot of other actors can
and maybe and people just in general can
relate to something
along these lines where you're your own
toughest critic you know
so in seeing some of the episodes
earlier before
any release like when they were kind of
in early editing stages
i believe i had caught myself in an
episode and
really laid into myself you know however
i did that
um but was like you need to step it up
and
and just kind of um reset the bar for
myself because we we know you know
only we know our own potential kind of
thing i think
and we set our own expectations in some
way
and if we're not striving towards that
then what are we doing you know that's
exactly why i asked that question
because i feel like who knows
who out there kind of needs to hear that
if they're stuck in a rut need to find
that in themselves
there's like there's levels of it like i
remember
after you saw whatever episode that was
and you like kind of came to me and i
was like
like dude like okay we can all improve
right but like you're on jupiter let's
come back to earth and let's like figure
this out
i go out there sometimes i'll tell you
that you're still great and
you you can be great and still improve
like i think that's an important sort of
thing to know as well
i need to to back pocket that myself and
i most certainly am right now
right do it like we can we can always be
improving but like
we're also way too hard on ourselves and
i think there's room for both
very much i know i was yeah kieran
kiernan would be like my confidant on
set too
i love it i mean i was always on set
that's the only place that i could
come like man i'm having a tough day on
set who can i turn to who's here
kiernan great here you're gonna get an
earful from me karen
yeah having followed you guys on social
media since the show began
you could feel that kind of radiating
through i don't know my phone screen or
your post how close you guys were and
how supportive of a group you were and i
feel like
that actually made the show even better
thank you perry i really appreciate that